hi I'm Casey mulligan from the
University of Chicago I'm going to talk
today about automated economic reasoning
you know many theorems in economics can
either be proven or disproven
automatically with quantifier
elimination the economic reasoning
package that I've made accepts the
expression of reasoning and the format
traditional to our field and then
automatically recognizes the theorem is
a special case of tarski xalbert using
Mathematica z-- resolve function the
package eliminates quantifiers and then
interprets the operators it's really my
pleasure to be part of this conference
and I can personally convey my gratitude
to the whole Wolfram team you know for
the amazing and useful products that
they've put together it really helps
help me do my job
and I really appreciate what you guys do
now this presentations about automated
economic reasoning and all that Wolfram
has to offer in the social sciences and
related fields now these are areas where
computation is already for a long time
been the norm for statistical analyses
but on the other hand deductive
reasoning and by that I mean deriving
conclusions from assumptions has largely
been left behind that computational
revolution and I had found this to be
strange because at some level I thought
you know House deduction different than
statistical inference that's long been
done with computers and sure enough the
technology has been available but it's
been a well-kept secret
from those doing deduction deriving
assumptions from conclusions so what
I've built is a package that I hope I
intend to kind of get this secret out as
well as helping myself be an economics
professor write write books and do
analysis of federal policy the package
does two basic things first it takes the
abstract notation that's conventional in
in my field and recognizes it as
nonetheless special cases of
alfred tarski 'he's non linear algebra
and that first step is where I think
Mathematica was indispensable I'm not
sure any other software could have
helped so easily to recognize the tarski
that's in everything and then the second
step is to is the deduction to pass the
tarski problem to a non-linear SMT
solver or a quantifier elimination
engine and Mathematica has one of those
engines in fact my experience it's the
most robust engine quantifier
elimination engine there is and often
it's the fastest although not always the
fastest no that's just my cheat sheet
okay so to anybody who's got Mathematica
and connected to the Internet can use my
package you just say get economic
reasoning comm and that'll download an
EM file and you get a little welcome
screen here we're going to use some of
the extras today
and then you could get started with get
started and you get a template that
tells you well give me a list of
assumptions and hypotheses and we'll
look at whether that hypothesis can be
concluded from the assumptions logically
now for a beginner that can be
intimidated it's a blank slate how do I
fill in the blank slate so I'm trying to
help and I've assembled quite a library
of examples if you click on examples
you'll get a pop up what you cannot see
and I'm gonna drag it over when you're
not in presentation mode you're gonna
pop up like this and I've sorted the
examples different ways for example we
have examples above many many different
things the Laffer curve is one of my
favorites this first one's a problem I
give the very smartest people in
economics I give them the economics
problem a real economics problem and
they mess it up but the computer never
does another one that I do is I do a lot
of Taxation analysis we have a bunch of
those so these are all notebooks that
you click you can download you can see
how I filled in the blanks and you can
go ahead and you can type over that or
be inspired to do your own thing now to
be to be clear you know I'm not the
engine here is not referring to the
examples it hasn't memorized the
examples the example is just for the
people to get introduced every problem
is solved from scratch without any
reference to these examples so let's go
back to the template what's going to
come out of here well what's going on
inside I'm using Mathematica resolve
function and that's amazingly powerful
to really do two nonlinear sad SMT
problems the first question is is there
a counter example is there a case when
the assumptions are true and the
hypothesis is false so that puts you in
a column and the other thing it does is
say well is there an exam
we're both hypothesis and assumption are
true and then it's going to spit out one
of these four results so that'll be the
output we can try here the easiest
economics example I could think of so
you don't have to rely on the machine
but you'll see that the machine gets the
right answer so in this easy example we
say price times quantity is expenditure
that's economics jargon then we're gonna
say well if the price were positive and
the quantity positive would expenditure
be positive of course it has to be true
there's no counter example we all know
that but let's see what the machine does
and it it says true there's no counter
examples you also got another pop-up
which I'll bring over here a dashboard
that shows a little bit about what
happened in the computation and some
next steps the next steps part the
different buttons it's kind of like the
Mathematica suggestion bar same same
idea okay so let's take a non-trivial
example this is from econometrics or
statistics it's about the weather least
squares estimates are biased and what
conditions so we're going to look at a
kind of a regression setting here where
we have a dependent variable related to
two independent variables x1 and x2 and
an error term epsilon the coefficients
are beta 1 and beta 2 so we'll put that
in there part of the package it
calculates OLS regression coefficients
so if you ran a novel us regression in
this setting what would be the formulas
for the coefficients and that those are
the formulas now we're ready for a query
we want to know is well this first OLS
coefficient is do we expect it to be
equal to beta one in other words is it
was least squares an unbiased estimator
what are we going to assume well we'll
assume that the first regressor is not
trivial it has some variation and we'll
assume that the x1 is uncorrelated with
the error term and we want to ask the
machine
is that enough to assume one bias thing
if you've taken statistics think to
yourself what the answer is it's not
easy a lot of advanced undergraduate to
get this one wrong some number get them
right what I want you to notice before
we ask the machine see what's in blue
here so the X's and the beta's at
Epsilon's
they're in blue so they're completely
symbolic I've not pre-programmed these
things the vectors to be a certain
length or to have a certain form or they
have certain numbers in it this is all
abstract symbolic reasoning that's going
on here so now let's ask the Machine
what it says oh and it says there's
counter examples there's examples but
there's counter examples we're missing
an assumption in other words our
assumption or two or three and well
let's see if we can figure out what
those are wondering before we do that I
want to let's use the show space button
which is going to tell you start to tell
you how the package recognize this as a
tarski problem what variables does it
view as critical for their reasoning so
we do that and it found that there are
six six variables really these are the
elements of the grameen matrix for the
vectors and it also says hey we
recognize X 1 and X 2 and epsilon is
being vectors that all happen
automatically again this is not
pre-programmed it dist knows from
context that oh you must be talking
about vectors here that's that fact is
going to come in in a second here
okay so what else do we need to assume
but we just learned that there's not
enough assumption so what else could we
add now we're posing a question that's
not true or false anymore we want we're
posing a question where the answer is a
formula what extra assumption do we need
so it's not an in in the SMT space
anymore it's not a justice at question
it's a it's a quantifier elimination
question with free variables it's a bit
harder problem but Mathematica does the
harder problems many of the other
software don't do that so we have a
button for that but I'm gonna do with
the type version today so theory
sufficient scan with no arguments means
take the most recent problem and tell me
what assumptions I'm missing so it's
gonna run it found four possibilities
any one of these four would be enough by
itself as an extra assumption to make it
true
so I found my users love this when
they're told that they're proof isn't
right they always want to know what do I
got to add to it and here's four answers
for them and they only need one let's
just check and make sure that the first
one for example does it and yep sure
enough when you add the first one in
that's enough to guarantee that it's
unbiased now there's no counter examples
with this extra assumption another
question you might ask is do I have too
many assumptions are there assumptions
that I could get rid of well we got a
button for that too let's try that and
it found a bunch of assumptions that
could be dropped and it still be true
now you might say wait a second how can
there be a bunch of assumptions to drop
you didn't put in a bunch of assumptions
if a bunch means more than three what
happened here what's up with that well
the the package recognized this as a
vector problem as we saw earlier it
recognized that the key reasoning is
happening around the grameen matrix for
that vector problem which is a three by
three matrix
and so it automatically puts in
restrictions that all gourami and
matrices have to satisfy has to be
symmetric and positive semi-definite so
you had extra assumptions that we're
thrown in here because it knew that you
wanted them it knows that you're
reasoning about real valued vectors and
therefore crimeans have this property so
again you save yourself a lot of typing
and by having the that all done
automatically for us
okay here's a different problem from
labor economics and if you take a look
at the chart here there's two series
ones gray with squares let's look at
that one first that's a measure of
probably familiar I think New York Times
has probably published this series a
hundred times or something very close to
it shows wage inequality over time over
the years and you know in the 50 60's
and 70's wage inequality was pretty
stable but then we had this period of
time in the 80s and 90s maybe it's even
continuing today there's more and more
inequality the gray square series keeps
going up so that that's kind of the
background now let's look at the black
series it seems to track it but the
black series is a measure of equality so
what gives we have every time we get
more inequality we also get more
equality what's up with that and that
for a long time in my profession that
was viewed as a puzzle very curious
puzzle but I wrote a piece few years ago
arguing that no this is not a puzzle the
basic economics we use to think about
wages and inequality would actually
predict that the Equality would be a
consequence of the inequality and I want
to explore that reasoning here here with
the machine so where I'm gonna define
probably very few economists in the
audience and it's okay if you don't
follow each of the economic pieces here
I'll emphasize the computational pieces
but I'm going to define X is it again
this is all symbolic X is something that
happened over time I don't know what it
is that's why I don't give it a precise
name I call it X name it anything you
want it I guess but X is going to
increase inequality which is measured by
Sigma without this is a conceptual
experiment without changing the
employment rate of women or the average
potential wage of women and so that's
what I've defined here what do I mean
about X it's keeping employment constant
and keeping the potential wage constant
but it's increasing inequality so put
that in and then I'm going to be
interesting and well what's going on
with the average wage of working women h
is going to refer to the average wage or
human capital of working women and acts
did something to that over time and will
be interested in what is that something
qualitatively or practice even
quantitatively so that's kind of my set
up and then we can get a little bit more
set up to pose a query a few definitions
what do I mean by employment rate and
this is this this is when I refer to the
kind of standard model and economics of
wages and and human capital this is a
pretty standard model that's employment
this is I'll put that in the H is the
average wage of working women we'll put
that in notice what's in blue here you
need is not pre program doesn't have any
numbers that's a joint and our field we
interpret that as a joint probability
density function so what's gonna happen
when we start to do queries arm on this
and around this and it says true that
means there's no counter examples that
means you could never find you could
look in a huge space of probability
density functions and as long as you can
integrate it implicitly it can be
integrated you're never gonna find one
that'll generate a counter example to
what we're saying so that's what I mean
by symbolic one thing we'll want to
refer to is positive employment which
just means P positive and that there's
some inequality in the baseline that
even back in the 60s we had some
inequality and what happened is we added
to it so that completes the set up and
now we're ready for a query
once all we can check with this
experiment we've defined and starting
from kind of baseline conditions with
employment and inequality is it
necessarily true that the wages of women
would go up or would they be a
counterexample meaning we can't
necessarily conclude that based on the
assumption so we'll ask the Machine and
it says true
there aren't any counter examples
now I understand you probably didn't
follow a lot of the economic because
it's not your training that's okay but
from the computational point of view
it's a couple things I want to say first
of all the tarski framework is it is a
lot more applicable and you might first
thought tar skis frameworks usually
described as polynomial algebra but wait
a second I had dot products I had double
integrals those don't look like
polynomials but if you think of the
problem and broad enough terms it is a
polynomial problem and the package
automatically recognizes those brought
enough terms and turns it into that so
that's the first thing I want you to
notice the second thing you notice is
these are real problems
I did not concoct these as toys for
Mathematica to play with these are
things that I deal with and people in my
profession deal with all the time and
the machine can do that what my real
regret here is I wrote that paper it's
11 years ago now I wish I had the
machine because when we wrote that paper
we assumed a joint Gaussian distribution
which is a tragedy for two reasons
number one it's much more narrow we just
were reasoning about any Joint
Distribution function that you can
integrate not just the joint Gaussian
and second of all it was a big pain in
the butt to do calculations with joint
Gaussian you can see the calculation is
pretty simple there's only a few basic
things going in here that you know I
really wish I had the machine but better
late than never
right
I want to say a few words about teaching
because I think that's where you start
in teaching not just economics but
computation the young people are they're
gonna be the ones are receptive and and
we'll take this somewhere so what I do
in teaching is we can close this done
with this
I don't do proofs anymore I in the old
days I used to and my colleagues still
do take drag students through step by
step proving something I just show them
hey the machine said is true trust it
know that we don't stop there what we do
is repetition I give them the machine I
say look there's the assumptions I use
that's hypothesis you change it you edit
you add assumptions you take them out
you see what happens and then you end up
having a lot of repetitions instead of
me dragging through them through one
theorem they can do 30 theorems that are
closely related and then they start to
get a different kind of understanding
and one that's serves the comparative
advantage of the people as opposed to
the machine so I've been very happy with
that the other thing that I think comes
out of this as calculus is not a
prerequisite anymore a lot of people
haven't taken calculus a lot of college
students haven't taken calculus or if
they did they're not comfortable with it
and those are people who and the old
days couldn't participate in my class
because that's was how I was
demonstrating a lot of things but
calculus in most classes that we use it
it's a shortcut it were you looking at
the local linear 'ti of the problem so
we're limiting ourselves to local
problems so we can make them linear to
make them easier but why we make it easy
who cares I don't have any mercy on this
machine let the Machine sweat right and
so now you can pose problems without
calculus non-local problems non-local
comparisons and my examples are all
sorted that way if you go through the
example browser I always explain are we
dealing with the local linear local
problem where calculus can be used and I
have to have that because my colleagues
are so used to calculus but what about
the non-local problems and there's a
bunch of non-local problems that are
really more interesting because most of
life is a non-local change not a local
change and then the students who are
participating in this they don't need to
know calculus anymore because I'm not
doing any local comparison so that's
that's pretty cool so glad to take your
questions and really appreciate all the
things well from folks too it's very
helpful
[Applause]